talk about Skyrim I've actually been
playing it a lot more lately than I both
want to or in thought I would I have two
characters already haha um wha network
games for like lunch break and one at
home and by lunch break I mean all
through the day when I pretend to work
um but anyway just basically you didn't
do weed into a full scored review we
kind of just did a you played for a few
hours to look at it see how it looks see
how it plays you have any quality of
life changes and whatnot yeah try out a
few mods maybe yeah um and I just want
to ask you and for the people watching
is it worth getting back into like is it
worth your time this time around is like
the remaster the special edition yeah
and I mean the best answer I can give to
that is gonna sound like a cop-out or
like whatever but it really does depend
on who you are and like if you've played
the game and what platform you're
looking to play on a lot of those
factors will dictate whether or not it's
actually worth upgrading so I mean if
you never played the game before then
yes absolutely Skyrim is fantastic and
this is like objectively now the best
way to play the game for a variety of
reasons I mean the visual updates are
only one of those reasons actually and
they've done a decent job I mean it's
you know I think I mentioned in that
text that you referred to at the top of
the segment you know it's it's not a
night and day difference it's not like
you you come into the game you're like
oh my god this is so overwhelmingly
beautiful but they've made some
important tweaks that that improve you
know your immersion in the game and even
the gameplay itself I think the example
that I cited in the in the text was I
mean playing the game years ago I would
often find that in darker areas that
enemies we kind of blend in because the
textures were so like you couldn't
distinguish it all just looked kind of
muddy and blended together and you could
be shot by somebody have no idea where
they are so that's not as much of a
problem anymore because the colors are
brighter the game just looks crisper in
general the textures are much more
detailed and just high resolution
Lighting's been improved depth of field
has been improved so none of those
changes are monumental or you know
completely game-changing but they're
enough that they improve the overall
experience which is kind of the key like
the game is so good you really just need
enough of a visual improvement to allow
you to enjoy it more and that's really
what special edition delivers and it's
only it's liked at 30 frames per second
is thirty per second people have
actually speculated that there's
eventually going to be a PS pro patch or
a Scorpio patch that bumps it up to
sixty but there's been no announcement
to that effect so who knows but yeah
currently the console versions are still
at thirty and one big criticism for
maybe not Cristen criticism but a lot of
people that have been playing on PC and
you know updating with mods and just
kind of updating its graphics and
whatnot say they've been playing this
version for how long now and like
obviously it's geared toward you know
console players who either didn't play
it or like me who played it back in 2011
a lot and with the expansions I forget
like how many hundreds of hours I put
into this game but I even find myself
wanting to get back in because I think
it came at a time of the year when I
didn't have something that required this
much patience and just kind of like it's
just enveloping me a lot more because
I've been playing titanfall 2 and Call
of Duty both are which fast-paced both
of which are fast paced and kinda you
know twitchy kind of shooters
Battlefield requires a little more
patience but I've just been playing so
many shooters that it's nice to play
something first person in this really
engrossing world and I still find that
I'm getting sucked into it even though
like I was just telling you guys I don't
really want to pee I don't know what
experience you had with Skyrim back
ahead you play a much not as much as you
I think I so when I joined GameSpot was
when skyrim came out and my job was
Troy's strategy guides and I had a guide
I was working on before I actually
officially started at GameSpot so I I
unfortunately had to like fit it into my
schedule so I'm actually looking forward
to this holiday going back and finally
like just taking all the time I freaking
need which is a lot of time which is as
mike has pointed out totally and like
and I can do that you know when I'm not
playing like a 70 hour game for review
like in a week or managing all sorts of
other stuff so yeah like I will gladly
put the time into this game I think it's
I think it's worth it I mean you have to
circle back to Mike's original question
is it worth it I mean for you as someone
who hasn't played as much of it as you
really wanted to then yeah it's an
unequivocal yes but I think even for for
other players it's potentially
worthwhile I mean one thing that I
actually failed to mention in the text
which was an oversight on my part is
that the game actually runs much better
even on pc so yes visually special
edition just the base game out of the
box with no mods doesn't actually look
substantially better than than what pc
players have already been playing but
there have been some like
behind-the-scenes updates for example in
runs that you can utilize more than four
gigs of RAM for example so changes like
that allow the game to run much more
smoothly so it becomes just a better
platform for mods and things like that
so it's no longer kind of like if you're
playing the game with a ton of mods it
won't be so sluggish you won't be
struggling under the weight of all the
things you've piled on top right I mean
it gives you a better experience simply
as a result of hey the game runs better
now so even for PC players who have been
improving the experience for themselves
over the years by adding mods this still
will actually be will offer an
improvement of a different kind for
those players and if you own all the DLC
if you previously purchased the DLC and
you on the base game you can just
download special edition for free
through Steam anyway so clearly it's
worthwhile so that's that's sort of the
side for PC gamers while we're on the
topic what kind of mods you try out and
how they work uh so I was mainly playing
on PlayStation which is pretty limited
unfortunately I think there are only 26
mods or at least the day that it
launched there were only 26 months
available you can also only have like
one gig worth of mods active at a time
on PC ps4 and Xbox one is 5 yes what
about after in terms of like actually I
don't know like Pete why like
technically is that the case I don't
know I just assume the ps4 is more
capable of like handling I think the
impression I get actually is that it's
related to Sony and agreements and
things like that it's not a matter of
like technical power it's not the ps4 is
incapable of handling more I think it's
it's something to do with the way that
Sony wants mods to be handled well
there's definitely some sort of policy
in place where they don't want
originally original assets like fan-made
stuff or things that play off of other
properties brought into the game like
that's one aspect of it but limiting the
amount of which I believe is the amount
of RAM that can be used well that
doesn't make sense no cuz exactly yeah
yeah I can't imagine why they would they
would limit that from a policy
standpoint from a hardware perspective
it doesn't make sense to me either
because it's not storing all the stuff
and Ram it would be feeding it into it
like any other piece of the game so yeah
uh yeah I do not know no interests
there's all kinds of different stuff
available already though like invincible
dogs big fan just weather updates things
like that
it's a pretty decent selection so far of
just like visual updates and small
gameplay tweaks and you know greater
effects things like that um it's nothing
I don't know there's no Thomas the Tank
Engine right which is a bummer amore but
like you can it's cool that that's even
an option and I'm excited there's going
to be more and more stuff added I mean
has to be vetted and approved by
Bethesda so that will slow the process a
little bit but there's already a pretty
decent variety of mods for console
players and the fact that there weren't
like you had no access to mods before
it's great that that's at least an
option now yeah I mean the mods are what
brought me back in at one point is well
after I played all the expansions I
remember frostfall was when I really
liked it actually like took the cold
weather into account you have to wear
like fur armor and whatnot so you didn't
just die of hypothermia
the survival based ones I really like it
kind of actually made me feel more
connected to the world because like
whether you're near Rifton and the
swamps is a lot different than whether
you're up near like I don't know more
Thal in the mountains and whatnot the
these the names of these towns my memory
serves but I think I was right something
like that yeah but I'm curious in terms
of like curating the model you said
Bethesda obviously has to approve them
but from your experience with the UI
like searching for mods with their the
filters helpful was the UI itself pretty
well laid out and everything it's pretty
basic yeah I mean it's so you have to
like pre select mods before you jump
into the game and you can enable and
disable your already selected mods from
within the game itself so it looks a
little inconvenient you can't just
decide mid game I want to browse mod
let's see what's available you actually
had to have like selected stuff before
jumping into the game from the main menu
we have the UI is fine I mean it's it's
you know just like a ticker of you know
thumbnails that you scroll through and
you can dig in and read all about what
you're about to enable like it's fine I
mean thankfully it doesn't impact the
experience because it's something that
you're doing sort of out of combat right
it's not like it's gonna impact the
gameplay so I mean I found it relatively
easy to define stuff I was looking for
although again the selection is somewhat
limited right now so that makes it
easier to find what you're looking for
sure less to dig through yeah I'm I'm
curious how they're going to like
control the flood of mods that they
could be putting on and I'm wondering
like obviously like again that's where
it comes back to it's probably best to
have this on PC so you could just use
whatever mods you want that are actually
just like readily available all over the
place I've been playing XCOM to pretty
much all year and
really like the mods that like Star Wars
mods and Halo mods we can actually swap
out individual weapons and yeah I don't
think Sony would be cool with that no uh
PC may be the place to be for this kind
of stuff yeah definitely and I know like
I do want to bring up the price of this
because a lot of people are kind of
wondering why they should pay its full
$60 right and everything with 60 bones
except if you're on PC and you already
own the existing expansion packs then it
was free yep yeah so I mean like I don't
know do you think that's justified beat
no I mean I remember a Pete Hines lita
says those PR had tweeted one day saying
like $60 for a remaster of a great game
you know mod support updated visuals if
you don't like it don't buy it well yeah
but that stands true for anything
regardless of the reasons he laid out
beforehand like yeah I mean yeah like 60
bucks like sure the game probably has
that value but at the same time like is
it a big enough difference you know
where you could spend $10 and buy the
original version and play it that way
like yeah I don't know that the
differences are so large especially for
a game that is still fundamentally the
same yeah again it's it's a remaster not
a remake so there really no content
changes are significant content changes
the DLC is already in there but like
again that stuff that's been available
for years like you could have already
purchased
I mean yet in terms of if you already
own a copy of this game and like you
know you have you have a version for
three sixteen years 360 still hooked up
to your TV like maybe go ahead and just
play that I mean I will say the one
thing that made the biggest difference
for me was the load times like oh my god
is so much faster cuz you go through a
lot of loading screens in that game like
every dungeon there are multiple
segments of the dungeon like every time
you duck into a story of load screen the
fact that those are now like literally a
quarter of the time is amazing it makes
the experience so much better but is
that worth 60 bucks I don't know
probably not that that's up for
individual consumers to decide like I
don't know what $60 means to you but
like they I think Bethesda could have
done more if they're gonna ask 60 bucks
for this but it's so targeted at the
people that are just gonna buy it
regardless of the price as someone who
collects and pays stupid amounts of
money for old games that don't that
don't last nearly as long as the price
tag might make you think I can
understand why some people would
definitely buy this and maybe it's just
a smart business move for Bethesda to
get all the money they can right away
and the stragglers who would maybe be on
the fence anyway they'll get them down
the road yes jeepers I mean I like as
much as I'm cynical about it I'm one of
those people who bought it even though I
have on 360 I have all the expansion's I
have on a PC as well I don't know why I
also don't know why I bought this but a
lot I write I am part of the problem
yeah and I I get that the amount of time
you could pour into this is definitely
equipment to $60 but is it I don't think
it's justified by YouTube after what
five years now and the original release
with all the expansions and the fact
that you know like you said if you
already have it it's free but you can if
you already have on a PC chances are it
will probably look like this or at least
play like this especially with the mods
which are much less limited on PC yeah
so I'm not completely sold on it
although I've already put like twelve
hours into it I'm gonna try to hold off
more listen I'm more excited for you
because you have an ink you yeah you and
played more much of it since it releases
yeah see what you know about Bethesda
and special edition like the game itself
is absolutely fantastic like one of my
favorite games of all time one of in my
mind one of the greatest RPGs of all
time flaws and all like I know it's a
very buggy game continues to be a buggy
game but man like just the amount of
side content and like the quality of
that side con and just that being lost
in that world and finding all the stuff
you never expected it's you can dive so
deep into that game and never touch the
main question have an amazing time for
hundreds of hours it's incredible it
says that has mastered the art of making
just walking around like magical it's
crazy just walking on that world between
the Mayan Skyrim and Skyrim what did I
say you said Bethesda has oh sorry well
I don't think every moment in Fallout no
fallout were Korean I guess but that's
another point like personally I would
rather play more fallout 4 I only bevor
played like 15 hours of it which is in
the grand scheme of things the Falla
isn't a ton so I'd rather play that
instead of scaring me I keep finding
myself there like Nick I played fallout
4 the other day so they're next to each
other on my playstation menu now and I
carry on and I'm always like hovering
over fallen see I'm just in play Skyrim
can see what am I you should play Doom
in stick and see what my orc Huntress is
up to uh doom is also really fun game
I'm just imagining like either like you
like a camera focused on your face
getting like closer as you like try to
decide between Fallout and Skyrim
wetting my eyes twitching and then you
flip over there I play
instead that's also fine but yeah so
that is scarran specialization so Scott
for all intents purposes you enjoyed
your time with it yeah but I love Skyrim
so here don't look at me so people like
you will probably enjoy it you like me
we'll enjoy it Pete you get the chance
to play it again oh yeah there are less
whether it's $60 or not yeah 60 bucks
are not like I said I think this is
objectively the best way to play the
game on consoles now I mean it's maybe
cynical to charge full price for it and
yeah I'm sure it'll be on sale in a
couple months but yeah if you're looking
for the gaming console this is the best
way to do it yeah so I discovered
special edition I don't know let us know
what you think tell us what you think
$60 is justified tell us whether you
just play it on PC if you played it
before if you're looking forward to
returning to it let us know in the
comments below